so I thought today we would look at the
topic of optimization it's one thing
that's it's been around in computer
science for years and I'm not talking
about the mathematical optimization that
um people do but I'm talking about
making your
code
optimal that might sound like I've
defined optimization in terms of itself
and actually there's there's a point
there and so the a says optimization is
the action or process of making the best
of something also the action or process
of rendering optimal the state or
condition of being optimal and that is
really what we're going to be talking
about today is how can we make our
computer programs when we write programs
the best computer program but there's a
question we have to ask first what are
we trying to optimize for what are we
trying to make it the best of do we want
it to be as fast as possible or do we
want to make it use the minimal amount
of memory in which case we're optimizing
for memory size or these days we might
even want to consider are we optimizing
for power usage if we're running on
something like a mobile phone or a
battery powered laptop we may want to
write our software so it uses as little
power as possible at the expense of
speed or memory usage when we optimize
something we're going to have to choose
whether we're more interested in the
speed that it takes to execute or
amount of memory usage or the power
usage so how do we go about optimizing
our software well the first thing to say
is that we don't no that's simple end
the video we don't
I may be joking there but probably the
most helpful statement ever said about
optimization with Don can in a paper
many years ago and he said premature
optimization is the root of all evil and
actually I think that makes a really
good point there's no point optimizing a
bit of code if it's not going to give us
a benefit when the program runs overall
so really we don't want to optimize our
program at all we just want to sit and
write our program and get a version that
works not worrying about the
optimization that's the first thing you
want to do when writing software writing
optimized software just get a version
that works works because then you can
use tools to sort of instrument that and
actually find out well which bits are
being slow where does the program spend
most of its time can I ask a question
yep is it not better to sort of design
it properly in the first place and
specify
um I mean we're taking that as red that
actually you'll have designed the
software and even if you are again the
same thing when you come to actually
implement it you don't want to try and
Implement an optimized version straight
away um whatever your design is you
would take that implement it and then
see which bits need optimizing we can
spend ages optimizing a bit of code
because we think it's an interesting
problem to try and optimize it and we
can produce a really nice solution only
to find that that piece of code is
called once at the start of the program
and so we've managed to shave off um a
tenth of a second off a piece of code
that's called once probably while the
person who was running the software had
gone to make a cup of coffee so they
never noticed all that work you'd put in
so we write the program first and then
we see whether it's taking too long to
execute or it uses too much memory for
the environment we want to run it in or
it's using too much power we can use
other tools um profilers various other
tools that are available to run the
program test what's happening as it's
running see which parts of the program
are using the most time or using the
most memory and then we focus our
attention in terms of optimizing them
looking at those parts of the program so
we don't go into this blindly and just
think right let's have some fun let's go
in and optimize this program this
function looks interesting let's rewrite
that we find out which parts of our
program are what we call the hotspots
and we start looking at those to try and
optimize them so first of all don't even
bother thinking about the optimum way to
implement it just get the program
working and get something that you can
test and you know that the program does
what you want to do then test it to see
which parts of it are need optimizing a
lot of computer programs are compiled
and the compiler does some optimization
for you so is it something you need to
do optimizing code so that's that's a
really great question question yes and
no so I mean these days I mean if you
gone back 40 years compilers were
terrible if you take written a
programing C and compiled it the chances
are that the code it would produced
would not be as good particularly on a
PC or home computer at the time as a
good programmer could have written in
raw assembler and so people would go and
rewrite it in assembler or optimize it
because they could get better code that
way these days the technology of
compilers has moved on a lot they all
have an optimizing step that you can
enable when you're compiling your code
in GCC for example you put the minus o
minus capital O flag with various
parameters to specify what type of
optimization you want there and it will
take your code and produce assembly code
or machine code that is as optimal as
the compiler can produce it and that's
great and again you should do that
before you try and optimize it yourself
but you can often find that actually
there are situations where if you think
about what the program's doing you can
probably come up with a better solution
than even the optimizing compiler can
but you need to know where where that's
worth doing and that involves knowing
what it is your code needs to do so for
example if you've got a program which
takes three days to execute and you can
shave a nanc off every iteration of a
loop it's
doing that may well not make that much
of a difference on the other hand if
you're writing a game and you've got
your screen being redrawn at 120 144
frames per second shaving a couple of
nanc off each iteration of a loop
drawing the graphics on screen or
something actually may benefit because
it might mean you can draw one it in one
frame rather than taking two frames to
draw things on the screen so again you
want to know what are the requirements
of the program how is it being used
before you start making optimizations
and I'm tending to talk more about speed
here but the same is true as if you're
optimizing for power or if you're
optimiz optimizing for um memory usage
as well you've got to make the same
decision we'll concentrate on optimizing
for Speed because that's what people
have tended to do in the past the best
way to optimize your program is to make
sure it's using the right algorithm um
you can use some sort of tips and tricks
and techniques that you can find in
books like Michael AB brush's the Zen of
code optimization looking at how you
could optimize programs to run on the
386 486 and the penum which shows how
old it is are the principles still the
same though so the principles are the
same or the sort of things to look at
but obviously um the CPUs have all
changed and that's when it comes to
optimizing for spee that's one of the
issues what may make your program run
faster on one CPU isn't necessarily the
same thing for another CPU today we'll
concentrate on the other side of
optimization what people tend to think
of more as optimization which tends to
be the sort of Tricks you'll find talked
of in books like that in web pages
talking about how to optimize things
which is just looking at you've written
code can you write it in a way that runs
faster by just changing the instructions
of a bit and doing the same sort of
thing but making a few changes to that
now to do that I'm going to write a very
simple program which copies a block of
memory so it's going to take in a
pointer to some memory void star and
we'll say that's the
destination and we're going to take in a
pointer to the source and we're going to
take in the number of bytes to copy and
the way that we could write this is we
could set up a pointer
internally to a bite we don't know what
it is so we'll just keep call it
unsigned it doesn't really matter for
this and I'm not going to put the cast
in just because it'll annoy people on
YouTube but we can assume that that's
put in I'm writing pseudo code here
we'll set up another pointer to point to
the source and then we'll set up a
counter I which we'll set to equal zero
and we'll say while I is less than n
that there we're going to set p++ equal
q++ make that a point otherwise it won't
work properly and then we will increment
I so that's a very very simple memory
copy program we copy one bite from the
source which is what the star uses
that's really bite from The Source
increment q and we'll write it to the
destination and increment P so we then
move on to point to the next bite and we
just go around that Loop until we've
copied n bytes from there so that reads
the bite there there and this one writes
a bite do you are you writing before
you're reading there or am I jumping the
gun uh no so this code's fine it'll read
it because we've got the equals here
it'll know that it's got to evaluate the
thing on the right before it can read it
and we're we're incrementing p and Q
there so let's have a look at this
program and see if there's a way we
could use some of the sort of tricks
that people have tended to think about
when they refer to optimizing things
that we could apply to this let's move
away from C and look at this in sort of
a machine code representation we'll see
what's actually happening here I'm going
to use Arm because it's sort of
relatively straightforward so we'll say
r0 contains the destination and we can
say R1 these are just registers these
just have the values in we can say we
move into R2 Z we're then going to load
a bite into R3 from the address in r0
We'll add one soorry in R1 there we'll
add one to R1
to move on to the next bite so we're
we're doing exactly the same but we're
sort of seeing the steps that are
involved in a bit more detail and we
then we'll Store The Bite in R3 into r0
and we'll add one to r0 like so this is
what effectively the C compiler would
generate for this if you were to write
it out and then we'd have a compare
instruction here that compares R2 with
R3 that should have been R4 there
there we are it's much easier writing
this on the computer we also need to add
r two with one here to count that we'll
compare them and we'll say while it is
less than we will loop around so we'll
go back around to Loop which we will
label here so now we can see the
individual things that are happening
we're loading a bite from memory from
the address R1 we're incrementing R1
we're adding one to it we're storing it
in the address in r0 we're incrementing
that we're incrementing the number we've
counted and we're comparing them and
each time around we go the loop we'll go
around this Loop however many btes we've
got there let's see how many
instructions it's going to take to copy
one bite so that's basically the bit in
the loop we'll ignore the setup cost
here cuz that's going to happen once
it's going to be a negligible cost
unless we're actually only copying zero
bytes in which case it'll take time we
should probably also have a branch to
the condition here just so that we
actually can cope with the case when
it's zero so how many instructions we
copy per per bite well basically it's 1
2 3 4 5 6 seven instructions so our
basic implementation is going to take
seven instructions per bite so can we
speed this up by speeding up we want to
take less instructions per bite well
okay there's some very simple things we
can do we can get rid of two
instructions straight away so we can get
rid of that instruction because the arm
CPU provides us with a instruction that
will automatically add one to the value
of R1 so we can get that for free if we
know what our CPU provides us and this
is something that the compiler would do
to optimize the code we're not doing
anything yet that the compiler wouldn't
do behind the scenes anyway it would
spot that and take it away we can do
exactly the same thing here we can take
that instruction there away and we're
now only doing five instructions per
Vite so just by knowing our CPU a bit
better we can remove two instructions
and that saves whatever percentage that
is it's what it's 5 over 7 more than a
quarter more than a quarter that's 25%
faster already just by knowing our CPU a
bit better and of course this is
something the compiler would do but
we're still taking five instructions to
copy one bite can we improve on that at
all well let's think about what we're
actually doing we are copying one bite
at a
time but could we copy more than one
bite at a time well the arm CPU along
with most CPUs is quite capable of
copying a single bite from memory or
copying four bytes from memory think
about it in terms of an analogy if you
have a pile of books you have to take
from one side of the room to the other
if you carry one book at a time it'll
take you longer than if you carry four
books at a time exactly the same thing
here if we copy more information each
time then we'll have to take less time
to do it so let's see how we could do
that so we got the same thing r0 points
to the destination R1 points to the
source R2 is our counter and then R3 is
the number of bytes to copy so the first
thing we need to do differently this
time is that we've still got the number
of bytes to copy but we're now going to
be copying four bytes at a time so we
need to divide R3 by four so we can do
that either by writing a divide routine
but because it's a power of two we can
do that very quickly by just shifting it
to places to the right in binary which
will divide it by four so we can do that
on the arm CPU like so and I'm going to
use a different register here ASR by 2
so this is divide by 4 now why do we
need to divide by four so we only need
to do a quarter of the number of
iterations around the loop because each
time we're copying four bytes in each
time so we need to divide it by four
except there's a problem we're doing
integer division what's 7 divided by
four oh okay yeah so we're going to have
a problem with odd numbers so we're
going to have a problem with odd numbers
or numbers which aren't a multiple of
four so we can test with the the number
is wholly divisible by four and if it is
we can just copy it using this method if
it isn't we can copy it using this
method and then copy the remaining one
two or three bytes that we need to to
finish off copying it now that's fine um
as long as we're not copying one two or
three bytes because then we've got all
the overhead of testing for it so that's
again something you perhaps want to know
about your program if you're copying
lots of small bits you probably don't
want to use this optimized routine
because it would actually end up being
slower again you need to know about how
your program works to optimize it to
make it run more efficiently and then we
set up R4 like that then what do we do
well we set up R2 again as
before comma zero set to be zero jump to
our condition we're going to have our
loop again so we're going to load in
this time we're going to load in 32 bits
so we haven't got the B there for bite
we're going to put that into R5 then
we're going to take that from R1 this
time though we're going to add on four
at the end cuz we've copied with four
bytes and so we want to step on to the
next four bytes likewise we're then
going to store that back no B again
into the address at r0 because we want
to copy four bytes each time so we add
on four rest of the code is the same we
compare R2 with R4 this time because
that contains the division by four if
it's less
than we jump back to Loop and this is
where our conditional is there so this
time we still take one two three hang on
why do we have four before and I've
missed out the add instruction there we
are add R2 comma r2a hash one so this
time we've still got five instructions
one 2 3 4 five but we will execute them
five instructions now per four bytes
rather than per bite so this time we'll
execute these five instructions a
quarter of the number of times
that we had to here so here we're doing
it five per B here we're doing it five
per four bytes plus the setup cost we're
ignoring the setup cost so just making a
simple change like that can make our
program it's only taking a quarter of
the speed and again this is something
that the compiler May well spot actually
modern compilers can sort of make these
optimizations now that works well for
something as simple as this because
actually we're using a sort of simple
example but actually we can take this
further you can use what something is
called Loop and rolling and this is
great if you know exactly how many times
you want to copy something so rather
than just copying four bytes at a time
now in reality there are instructions
and copy more than four bytes at a time
on most CPUs we'll ignore them for now
the same approach can take what we could
do instead is have our Loop look like
this load into R5 from R1 poed there so
we load in four bytes and then we store
those four bytes okay there's no change
there but then what we do is we load in
another four bytes and then we store
another four bytes here and we keep
doing this to make our Loop have more
iterations in it but they're explicitly
unrolled so the loop now here we would
copy eight bytes and if we were to loop
around there we'd copy eight bytes or we
could say make it do 16 bytes or 32
bytes and that would mean that the cost
per 32 bytes would be lower because we
wouldn't have to keep testing whether we
come to the end of the loop or not we
could sort of gain a speed up then so
what we're trying to do is reduce the
number of instructions we're executing
per bite of memory that we copied so
unrolling the loop can make things
faster now the problems you get
interesting problems is that gets too
big it then doesn't fit into your CPU
cache and so we start to slow your
program down um so finding out what size
works well really is dependent on what
CPU you're using and what you're doing
but the important thing is that don't do
this until you actually know where you
need to do it and there are places that
you need to look at it with this example
we just looked at one way that we could
speed up by changing the code there are
other approaches that you can take to
optimizing your program that do similar
things or different things so you can by
changing the way you store your data in
a program make your program run faster
it seems counterintuitive and we'll look
at it in another video probably but if
you change the order in which your data
stored um then you can make it much
quicker to access the uh data for
certain types of operations and as I
said if you really want to get some
speed increases these sort of tips and
tricks are good for things like a memory
copy routine which gets called a lot in
a lot of different places and you want
it to be as fast as possible but they're
probably not the tricks you want to
spend your time on in your sort of
everyday program unless you really need
the speed there um for example if you're
writing a video decompression algorithm
or something as part of a game then
perhaps yes you do want to do the sort
of Loop and rolling because it needs to
be fast it needs to get the data within
a certain limited amount of time um so
that they can display each video frame
on screen at the right time so if you
look at the code for ffmpeg you will see
these techniques being applied there to
make it as fast as possible on whatever
CPU it's running but for most programs
finding the right algorithm will give
you a far better benefit in terms of
speed again I'm optimizing everything to
the hilt test and so we'll run speed
test back so our binary search is
working now what would have happened is
someone implemented this based on some
textbook it works fine they considered
their job done for the day and they went
home right